موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
النا انظمه الدفاع الجوي حبطت هجوما
بطائره مسيره الاوكرانيه على قاعده عسكريه
في مقاطعه سيراتوف جنوب شرقيه عاصمه موسكو
وقالت الوزاره ان ثلاثه جنود روس قتلوا
جراء سقوطي حطام الطائره المسيره قال وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني بين الحكومه
الاوكرانيه تسعى لعقد قمه سلاما بحلول
نهايه شهر فبراير المقبل وانه يفضل ان
تكون في الامم المتحده مع الامين العام
انطونيو غوتيلاش كوسيط المحتمل وفق تعبيره
في المقابل رفض الكريم للامكانيه اجراء
مفاوضات في الامم المتحده بشروط اوكرانيا
وقال المتحدث باسم الكرم
ان بلاده لا تتبع شروط الاخرين في التفاوض
ابدا
نقلت وكاله تويوتا الروسيه عن وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافراف ان اوكرانيا
تعلم مطالبه موسكو بشان نزع السلاح
والتخلص من من وصفهم بالنازيين وانها ان
لم تلبي هذه المطالب فسيتولى الجيش الروسي
المساله
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان 71
طائره صينيه ما بين مقابل
الدفاع الجوي للجزيره في اكبر تواجد صيني
حتى الان من جهته قبل الجيش الصيني وانه
سيتخذ جميع الاجراءات اللازمه للدفاع عن
السياده البلاد وسلامه ياراضيها
واخي ردي فعل امريكي قال متحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي ان الولايات
المتحده تشعر بالقلق اذا اما وصفه بالنشاط
العسكري لاستفزازي للصين بالقرب من طيوان
قال الامين العام للاتحاد التونسي للشغل
لنور الدين الطب وبين الاتحاد بدا مشاورات
من اجل بلوره تصور لمبادره مع منظماتي
وقوى المجتمع المدني لانقاذ البلاد واضاف
الطبوبي انه لو كانت هناك راحه عقل سياسي
وحنكه لدى اصحاب القرار لكان الرئيس قيس
سعيد قد التقط رساله الشعب وذلك من خلال
نسب العزوف عن المشاركه في الانتخابات
التشريعيه الاخيره
من جهته قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان
العمليه الانتخابيه ستتواصل وان الشعب
سيقول كلمته في الانتخابات واتهم سعيد
اطرافا لم يسمها باختلاق الازمات ومحاولته
الدوله على حد تعبيره
الكل يرتفع عدده وضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده الى نحو 50
قتيلا معظمهم في مدينه بافلو بولايه
نيويورك وصدق الرئيس جو بعيدا على اعلان
الطوارئ في نيويوركال الاكثر تضررا لتوفير
الدعم للولايه وتسببت العاصفه في الغاء 15
الف رحله جويه وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي
عن اكثر من مليون شخص واغلاق عدد كبير من
الطرق
اشكركم على متابعه
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]